This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Thank you for helping us keep PDX safe and secure. For Gavida, for us, please proceed to a white cagey telephone in the press seal. I flew into the Portland Airport recently, and when I got off the plane, I took a picture of my feet, in keeping with the local custom. A foot selfie. That's producer Julie Sabatye, host of the podcast, rendered, formerly known as Destination DIY. She lives in Portland.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。感谢您帮助我们保持波特兰机场的安全。为了加维达，为了我们，请前往新闻封锁区的一个白色笼式电话。我最近飞往波特兰机场，下飞机后，我按照当地习俗拍下了我的脚的照片。一张足部自拍照。那是制作人朱莉·萨巴蒂尔，播客节目《Rendered》（前身为《Destination DIY》）的主持人。她住在波特兰。
And I almost always take a foot selfie when I'm at PDX, the Portland airport. I think I do it most often when I come home. Like, here I am, I'm back in Portland. The feet are actually not the most important thing about a Portland airport foot selfie. It's actually what's under your feet, the famous PDX airport carpet. It's allowed to suddenly 80s teal color with a repeating geometric pattern. Like any carpet you might see in an airport or a hotel lobby or an office building, it's probably not what you'd choose for your living room. The design I'm told is based on the way the runways and lights look from the air traffic
当我身处波特兰机场（PDX）时，我几乎总是会拍一张足部自拍照。我想我最常在回家的时候这样做。比如，我在这里，我又回到波特兰了。其实，双脚并不是波特兰机场足部自拍照中最最重要的部分。真正重要的是你脚下的东西——著名的PDX机场地毯。它采用了突兀的80年代蓝绿色调，并带有重复的几何图案。就像你在机场、酒店大堂或办公楼里可能看到的任何地毯一样，它大概不会是你为自己客厅挑选的风格。据我所知，这个设计的灵感来源于从空中交通
control tower, and also on the radar screen that the air traffic controller sees with that sweeping line going around and around, and the dots are the little blips representing airplanes. It's hard to say if it's the pattern people are responding to or the bright teal background color, but one thing is for sure. The carpet is very, very, beloved. There are even signs in the airport now saying, tweet your feet with the hashtag pdxcarpet. And it goes deeper than that.
控制塔俯瞰时跑道和灯光的视觉效果，同时也来源于空中交通管制员在雷达屏幕上看到的景象：一条扫描线周而复始地旋转，而那些小亮点代表着飞机。很难说人们喜欢的是这种图案还是明亮的蓝绿色背景，但有一点是肯定的。这块地毯非常、非常受人喜爱。现在机场里甚至还有标语，写着用话题#pdxcarpet在推特上晒出你的脚。而且情况远不止于此。
Meet Emma. She actually has a pdx carpet inspired tattoo. It hurt a lot. Emma Milken is a 21-year-old Portland native, which means a lot of the carpet in the airport is actually older than she is. She got a tattoo of the carpet pattern on her back. This side and so yes, my left. Emma traveled a lot as a kid.
认识一下埃玛。她甚至有一个受PDX地毯启发而纹的纹身。这真的很疼。埃玛·米尔肯是土生土长的波特兰人，今年21岁，这意味着机场里的大部分地毯其实比她还要老。她在背上纹了地毯的图案。这边，所以是的，在我的左边。埃玛小时候经常旅行。
Her parents are divorced and her dad lives in LA. I think the first time I ever took a flight as an unaccompanied biner, I was probably 11, and I was freaking out. But the carpet had this kind of calming effect on her. On my way, that was kind of like my send off, the carpet was there. And I knew that it would probably be there when I got home. Several years later, when Emma decided to take the plunge and get a tattoo of the Portland carpet design, she realized she was not the carpet's only admirer, not by a long shot. When I got the tattoo, I posted a picture of it on Instagram. And one of my followers tagged at PDX Carpet upon further
她的父母离异了，她爸爸住在洛杉矶。我想我第一次作为无成人陪伴儿童坐飞机时大概11岁，当时我吓坏了。但这种地毯对她有一种类似镇静的效果。在我出发的路上，它就像是我的欢送仪式，地毯就在那里。而且我知道当我到家时它可能也还在。几年后，当埃玛决定下定决心去纹一个波特兰地毯图案的纹身时，她意识到自己并不是地毯唯一的崇拜者，远非如此。当我纹完身时，我把它的一张照片发到了Instagram上。我的一位粉丝标记了@PDXCarpet。经过进一步
inspection. I was like, oh my goodness, the carpet has an Instagram. The carpet has a Twitter and a Facebook page. And that's kind of when I knew that it was this kind of notorious Portland entity. It's important to know that the airport communications department says they are not running any of the social media accounts devoted to the PDX carpet. Emma says that occasionally people on social media make fun of her tattoo. But I'm just sitting back and letting people say what they want about it, but I am in love. I used to live in Boston. I cannot imagine telling Bostonites like, I'm obsessed with the airport carpet at Logan
观察，我想，哦天哪，这个地毯竟然有一个Instagram账号。地毯还有一个推特和一个脸书主页。也就是在那个时候，我知道了它已经成为了一个臭名昭著的波特兰标志性事物。需要说明的是，机场通信部门表示他们并没有运营任何专门针对PDX地毯的社交媒体账号。埃玛说，偶尔社交媒体上的人会取笑她的纹身。但我只是坐视不管，由得他们去说关于它的看法，但我已经深陷爱河了。我以前住在波特兰。我无法想象对波特兰人说，比如，我迷上了洛根机场的机场地毯
and having someone go, yeah me too. Jeremy Dunn is a designer in Portland and he's another fan of the carpet. A couple of years ago, he decided to have some socks made with the carpet pattern on them. He spent about $500 on the minimum order, which was 72 pairs. So he was hoping some people would want to buy them. He posted them on our Instagram account and I think it was an hour, maybe two hours, and
然后有人回应说，哦，我也是。杰里米·邓恩是波特兰的一名设计师，他也是地毯的另一个粉丝。几年前，他决定制作一些印有地毯图案的袜子。他在最低订购量（72双）上花了大约500美元。所以他希望有人会想买它们。他把它们发到了我们的Instagram账号上，我想是一个小时，也许两个小时，然后
they were all sold out. The carpet socks were so popular that Jeremy quit his day job and opened up a retail space. Jeremy socks are actually sold in the airport now, alongside many other items emblazoned with the carpet pattern. T-shirts, coffee mugs, throw pillows, tote bags, stickers, keychains, bike helmets, water bottles. There's even a PDX carpet IPA from a local brewery called Rogue. That's what's so interesting to me about this whole carpet phenomenon. It's great for PDX, it's basically free marketing for them.
它们就全部卖光了。地毯袜子太受欢迎了，以至于杰里米辞掉了正职工作，开辟了一家零售店。现在，杰里米的袜子实际上已经在机场出售了，旁边还有许多其他印有地毯图案的商品。T恤、咖啡杯、抱枕、托特包、贴纸、钥匙扣、自行车头盔、水瓶。甚至还有一家名为Rogue的当地酿酒厂生产的PDX地毯IPA啤酒。这就是我对整个地毯现象最感兴趣的地方。这对PDX来说太棒了，这基本上是给他们的免费营销。
But if the airport had tried to create this kind of fervor for the carpet, there's no way it would have caught on, at least not like this. I love this carpet. I love it. It's like a big thing, everyone buys socks and t-shirts. It just kind of represents Portland,
但如果机场试图为地毯制造这种狂热，它绝不可能流行起来，至少不会以这种方式。我爱这块地毯。我太爱它了。这是一个很大的轰动，每个人都买袜子和T恤。它只是代表了波特兰，
like we're kind of known for this in our airport, this carpet. It makes traveling a little bit more enjoyable, I guess, when I'm in the airport. We always do this selfie, you know, the foot thing. But maybe there's something that's just secretly magical about it. Oh, get a room, people. People have extreme, unprecedented, inordinate amounts of affection for the carpet at P.D.X. When you ask people why they love the carpet so much, they pretty much all say the same thing. When they see it, it reminds them that they're home. And that's sweet, but like so many great love stories, I'm afraid this one is coming to
就像我们的机场以这种地毯而闻名一样。我想，当我在机场时，它让旅行变得更愉快了一点。我们总是拍这种自拍照，你知道的，拍脚的那种。但也许它里面有什么东西是暗中带有某种神奇魔力的。哦，找个房间吧，各位。人们对P.D.X.地毯有着极端、前所未有、极其大量的喜爱。当你问人们为什么这么喜欢地毯时，他们的回答几乎都一样。当他们看到它时，它提醒他们自己到家了。这很甜蜜，但就像许多伟大的爱情故事一样，我恐怕这个故事要迎来
a tragic end. That is the sound of Portland's heart being ripped out of its chest. Speaking of Pnex, workers are replacing the airport's famous carpet, you know that sea of teal with the red and purple blue accents. It's always hard to say goodbye, especially for travelers with an emotional attachment. A person came up to me and said, oh I love your tattoo. Did you know that they've already started tearing it up and I just kind of felt my heart sink. For carpet it's actually had a pretty long life. The oldest sections
一个悲惨的结局。那是波特兰的心脏被从胸膛中硬生生挖出来的声音。说到P.D.X.，工人们正在更换机场著名的地毯，你知道的那片带有红紫色和蓝色点缀的蓝绿色海洋。说再见总是很难，尤其是对那些对地毯有着情感依恋的旅客而言。一个人走到我面前说，哦，我喜欢你的纹身。你知道他们已经开始把它撕掉了吗？我顿时觉得心头一沉。对于地毯来说，这其实已经有了相当长的寿命。
of carpet have been in the airport since the late 1980s. There are things that you just can't repair. You can't just patch your way out of it. It really just looks tired and like it's served its life well. That's Robin McCaffrey. She's an engineering project manager at the Port of Portland, the agency that controls the airport. She's in charge of the Carpet Removal Project, which started in late January. Can you describe what you're doing, Ruther? I'm hooking the clamp to the carpet so the machine can pull it up. Mike MacLeaks works for 4M floor covering.
最古老的地毯自20世纪80年代末以来就一直在机场里。有些东西就是无法修复。你不能只是靠打补丁来解决问题。它看起来确实很疲惫，就像是已经完成了它光荣的使命。那是罗宾·麦卡弗里。她是波特兰港（管理该机场的机构）的一名工程项目经理。她负责1月下旬开始的地毯拆除项目。鲁瑟，你能描述一下你在做什么吗？我正在把夹子勾到地毯上，这样机器就能把它拉起来。迈克·麦克利克斯为4M地面铺装公司工作。
Actually, he helped install the carpet here at the end of the Seacon course in the mid-1990s. I laid all of this in 1995 for Rubenstein's contract carpets. So do you have any kind of attachment to it? None at all. You're not sorry to see it go. It's just carpet, that's my opinion. The machine they're using to remove the carpet looks like a cross between a motorized wheelchair and a zamboni.
事实上，他在20世纪90年代中期帮助安装了这里海康航站楼（Seacon course）的地毯。我在1995年为鲁宾斯坦合同地毯公司铺设了所有这些。所以你对它有什么依恋吗？完全没有。你不会为它的离去感到难过吗？它只是一块地毯，这就是我的看法。他们用来移除地毯的机器看起来介于电动轮椅和冰车之间。
It's called a panther. You attach the carpet to the machine and drive it forward to pull up these huge sections of carpet all at once. Most of this work will be done at night so it can have minimal impact on travelers. And it's going to take a long time. 13 acres of carpet does not get panthered away overnight. If all goes well, and perfectly, it will be earlier than November, but we're giving it a healthy window
它叫做黑豹（panther）。你把地毯连接到机器上，向前驾驶它，就可以一次性拉起这些巨大的地毯。大部分工作将在夜间进行，以便对旅客的影响降到最低。而且这需要很长的时间。13英亩的地毯不可能在一夜之间就被黑豹机清除干净。如果一切顺利且完美，它会比11月早，但我们给它留出了一个充裕的时间窗口
and we're saying before Thanksgiving of this year, it will be completely done. When the carpet is all removed, most of it will be sent back to the manufacturer and recycled, but not all of it. They're giving away 4 1,000 square yard pieces. Businesses will have to submit proposals to get one, outlining what they plan to do with the carpet, how they will store it in the meantime, and how they will eventually make it
我们说在今年感恩节之前，它将完全完成。当地毯被全部拆除后，大部分将被送回制造商处进行回收，但并非全部。他们正在赠送4块1000平方码的碎片。企业必须提交获取其中的一块的提案，概述他们打算如何处理地毯，他们将如何在此期间存放地毯，以及他们最终将如何使它
available to the general public. Whatever happens to the old PDX carpet, one thing is for sure. Its replacement has some big shoes to fill. People are going to hate it. Well, hopefully not. It might be a perfectly great design, but people will still hate it. They'll say, why didn't you replace all the carpet and use the same but-loved design? If they had decided to just re-carpet with the same design, that would have been cool.
向公众开放。无论旧的PDX地毯发生什么，有一件事是肯定的。它的替代品有一些很难填补的空缺。人们会讨厌它。嗯，希望不会。它可能是一个非常棒的设计，但人们仍然会讨厌它。他们会说，你们为什么不更换所有地毯并使用同一个备受喜爱的设计？如果他们决定只用相同的设计重新铺地毯，那将是很酷的。
See? Yeah, it does seem like the most obvious solution. But the decision to replace the carpet was made back in 2008 Before all the foot selfies and hashtag pdx carpet. I don't think at that time there was an awareness of that great sentiment that exists in the community for the carpet That we became aware of more recently. Did you ever consider Replacing the carpet with the same design? I think that we had thoughts about people asking that question.
看？是的，这似乎是最显而易见的解决方案。但更换地毯的决定早在2008年就做出了，那是在所有的足部自拍照和话题#pdxcarpet出现之前。我认为当时人们并没有意识到社区里对地毯存在着那种巨大的情感，这种情感是我们最近才意识到的。你有没有考虑过用相同的设计来替换地毯？我想我们考虑过人们会问这个问题。
Once we were well into it, and it already kind of come up with a conceptual design. Now, when you walk through the airport, you can actually see a sizable swatch of the new carpet. It's a darker green with a repeating geometric motif that's reminiscent of the old carpet, but busier. The business of the new design actually helps hide dirt and other wear and tear. In fact, there's a couple of different versions of the new design, one that's extra busy that they'll lay in higher traffic areas.
一旦我们深入其中，并且它已经想出了一个概念设计。现在，当你走过机场时，你实际上可以看到很大一块新地毯。这是一种更深绿色的地毯，带有重复的几何图案，让人想起旧地毯，但更繁复。新设计的繁复实际上有助于隐藏污垢和其他磨损。事实上，新设计有几种不同的版本，其中一种特别繁复，他们将把它铺在人流量更大的区域。
It looks like a tropical Jimmy Buffett version of the airport carpet and not in a good way. Jeremy done the sock maker is not a fan. It seems very swoopy and like you know it has more curves to it and it's a little bit different green and it's a little has some yellow in there you know and I think those are all to me those are all things that are not as appealing. Are you gonna make socks of the new design? Yeah, um, probably not. Yeah, I think it's tough if people don't have an immediate love, everybody wishes that
它看起来像是一个热带吉米·巴菲特（Jimmy Buffett）版本的机场地毯，而且不是什么好兆头。袜子制造商杰里米·邓恩（Jeremy Dunn）不是它的粉丝。它看起来非常迂回，你知道它有更多的曲线，而且是一种略有不同的绿色，里面有一点黄色，你知道，我认为对我和所有人来说，这些都是不太吸引人的地方。你会用新设计做袜子吗？是的，嗯，可能不会。是的，我认为如果人们没有立刻产生爱意，那就很艰难了，每个人都希望
their design work was immediately adored. Michelle Vowe is a partner at Hennaberry Eddy, the firm that took on the unenviable challenge of designing the replacement carpet. And like most design work, there's a lot of thought and consideration that went into it. The inspiration for this had a lot to do with what you see from the air as you're coming in. And that green color that's the main background color for the carpet is much like that experience
他们的设计作品立刻受到喜爱。米歇尔·沃（Michelle Vowe）是亨纳贝里·埃迪（Hennaberry Eddy）事务所的合伙人，该事务所承担了设计替代地毯的艰巨任务。像大多数设计工作一样，其中融入了许多思考和考虑。这个灵感的来源很大程度上与你从空中飞来时看到的景色有关。那种作为地毯主要背景颜色的绿色很像那种体验
of flying into Portland. We have a unique situation here where coming into Portland, the greenery of our surroundings come right up to the doorstep of our city. And those swoopy lines? Also we're looking at some of the that flight path, that pattern, and that curvature is your flying in. You know, if you were to look at kind of the way that aircraft curve around to align with the runways and come in.
飞入波特兰。我们这里有一个独特的情况，来到波特兰，我们周围的绿色植物一直延伸到我们城市的大门口。那些弯曲的线条？同时我们也在看一些飞行路线，那个模式，以及你飞进来时的曲率。你知道，如果你看一下飞机转向与跑道对齐并飞入的方式。
Did you ever think about how people's feet would look on the new carpet? No, no, actually, I didn't. Even with all this thought and care, designer Michelle Vo is fully aware that this new carpet is going to be a hard sell. But she hopes it will grow on people over time. I think that the new carpet going down is something that will become endearing. I hope that it will and maybe it won't reach cult status
你有没有想过人们的脚在新地毯上会是什么样子？不，不，其实我没有。尽管有这么多的思考和关怀，设计师米歇尔·沃（Michelle Vo）完全意识到这款新地毯将很难推销。但她希望随着时间的推移，人们会逐渐喜欢上它。我认为铺设的新地毯会成为一件令人喜爱的事情。我希望它会，也许它不会达到邪典般的地位
until 20 years out when it's time to replace it. But you know, that's okay, that's okay. You can't manufacture a cult following for an airport carpet. It has to happen on its own. You don't manufacture a cult following for an airport carpet. It has to happen on its own. You don't say. But I do think that part of the reason that people fell in love with the carpet is because people have a lot of love for the airport itself, which has kind of become a microcosm of Portland.
直到20年后的更换之时。但你知道，这没关系，这没关系。你无法为机场地毯人为制造一个邪典追随群体。它必须顺其自然。你不能为机场地毯人为制造一个邪典追随群体。它必须顺其自然。不用你说。但我确实认为，人们爱上地毯的部分原因是人们对机场本身有着许多爱，机场本身已经某种程度上成为了波特兰的缩影。
With local restaurants and food carts in the terminal, there's even a mini farmers market in the Seacon course. And so maybe the new carpet will eventually become a part of the airport the same way the old carpet did, crucial to the experience of coming home to Portland. Then again, maybe not. It's a lot like just having anything in your childhood replaced with something
航站楼内有当地的餐馆和美食车，海康航站楼甚至还有一个迷你农贸市场。所以也许新地毯最终会成为机场的一部分，就像旧地毯一样，对于回到波特兰的体验至关重要。话又说回来，也许不会。这很像把你童年时期的任何东西换成某种东西
you're kind of resentful towards the new, whatever it may be. And you could potentially grow to like it, but it'll never be the same as the original thing that you loved. Someday, Emma may love the new carpet. Like someday, I might learn to appreciate Star Wars the Phantom Menace with its Jar Jar Banks, emitter chlorine microbes that control the force. And... No, there's no way I'll ever like it. You hear me, George Lucas? I'll never like it.
你对新事物多少有点怨恨，无论它可能是什么。你可能会逐渐喜欢上它，但它永远不会和让你喜爱的最初事物一样。总有一天，埃玛可能会喜欢上新地毯。就像总有一天，我可能会学会欣赏《星球大战：幽灵的威胁》，里面有贾贾·宾克斯，还有控制原力的线粒体微生物。还有……不，我绝不可能喜欢它。你听到了吗，乔治·卢卡斯？我永远不会喜欢它。
You ruined it. You ruined everything! 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Julie Sabatier and Katie Mingle with Sam Greenspan Avery Truffleman and me Roman Mars, special thanks to Brian Kramer. Julie Sabatier's Render is an independent show from the public radio world carefully crafted for an audience of makers, doers and curious minds. It's fantastic. It's a new member of the Maximum Fun Network along with some of our favorites like Bullseye, my brother and my brother in me in the flop house, find it and subscribe at renderedradio.org.
你把它毁了。你毁了一切！本周的99%隐形由朱莉·萨巴蒂尔（Julie Sabatier）和凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）制作，萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、埃弗里·特拉夫特曼（Avery Truffleman）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）协助，特别感谢布莱恩·克拉默（Brian Kramer）。朱莉·萨巴蒂尔的《Rendered》是公共广播界的一个独立节目，专为创造者、实践者和好奇心强的人群精心打造。它太棒了。它是Maximum Fun网络的新成员，还有我们的一些最爱，比如《Bullseye》、《My Brother, My Brother and Me》和《The Flop House》，请在renderedradio.org上查找并订阅。
We are a project of 91.7 KALW San Francisco and produced of the offices of ArcSund and architecture and interiors firm, who has laid down some memorable carpet in its time in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. I'm throwing rocks tonight. Rocket dude. This was a valued rock. This was a uh... Yeah man it really tied the room together.
我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的一个项目，在ArcSund建筑和室内设计事务所的办公室制作，该公司曾在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心铺设过一些令人难忘的地毯。我今晚在扔石头。摇滚老兄。这是一块珍贵的石头。这是一块……是的，伙计，它确实把整个房间联系在了一起。
This was a valued uh... Did I do one together dude? My rug. Were you listening to the dude together. This was a value dog. Did I do one together, dude? My rug. Were you listening to the dude's story, Donnie? Plector. Were you listening to the dude's story? I was mulling. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook,
这是一块珍贵的……我做过一个吗，伙计？我的小地毯。你在听那个伙计吗？这块是珍贵的狗。我做过一个吗，伙计？我的小地毯。你在听那个伙计的故事吗，唐尼？普莱克托。你在听那个伙计的故事吗？我在沉思。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞，
we're all on Twitter and Instagram. Every runs the Tumblr, I make the Spotify playlist of 99PI songs, but I encourage you to explore the entire world of 99% invisible at 99PI.org. That rock really tied the room together did it not. Radio Topeo from PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们都在Twitter和Instagram上。每个人都在用Tumblr，我制作了99PI歌曲的Spotify播放列表，但我鼓励你在99PI.org上探索99%隐形的整个世界。那块地毯真的把整个房间联系在了一起，不是吗？来自PRX的无线电托佩奥。你此集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。